RONY ROZEN: Unless
you've been living
under a rock for
the past few months,
you know that there's
a new iPhone in town,
and it's significantly different
than all previous models.
Maybe you've been lucky
enough to get one by now.
Maybe you just spent
some time admiring
the new all-screen device
at the Apple Store near you,
or maybe you're counting the
days for your device to arrive.
Either way, some of you users
already have the new device,
and your app is being tested on
it whether you're ready for it
or not.
So let's try to make
sure you are ready.
You don't want your users
to be the first to test
your app on a new
device without knowing
what they should expect, right?
If you're using standard UIQ
components and Auto Layout,
you should be
relatively good to go.
If you are using
custom controls,
there may be some work
that needs to be done.
Either way, if you haven't even
tested your app on the iPhone
10 Simulator, now is a
good time to do that.
All you need is to run it
using Xcode 9 with iOS 11
as the base SDK, and make sure
you have a long storyboard.
Don't forget about landscape
mode, both left and right.
That's where you'll
encounter most of the issues.
One example of iPhone 10
compatibility in Google Apps
is the side navigation,
which is something
you may have encountered
in many of our apps.
This is how it used to
look before the iPhone 10
adaptations, and
this is a screenshot
from a recent release
of Google Photos.
Want to know how we did it?
Stay tuned.
Let's start with a general
description of the new iPhone.
It has a Super Retina display,
3x, 1,125 by 2,436 pixels.
The screen size is
375 by 1,812 points,
meaning same width
as the iPhone 6, 7,
and 8 but 145 points
taller, which means
roughly a 20% height addition.
This means an aspect ratio of
9 to 19.5 instead of 9 to 16.
Note that not all
of this new space
is necessarily yours to
use, as the status bar now
uses 44 points, and the
home indicator almost
doubles the height
of the toolbar
if and when one is used.
One more point about
the status bar--
since the status bar
is taller on iPhone 10,
if you're using a 20-point
constant somewhere,
now would be a
good time to change
that to use the real status bar
height for the current device.
Also, the status bar no
longer changes its height
for different situations such
as location tracking or phone
calls.
The space used by the status bar
on both sides of sensor housing
isn't used by the app, so if
you're hiding the status bar,
you may want to reconsider.
In landscape, due to the rounded
corners and the sensor housing,
the layout margins
are now 64 points
instead of just 20 points.
Note that Apple's human
interface guidelines indicate
that you should keep your UI
centered in landscape mode,
and not change the margins based
on the side the sensor housing
happens to be in at the moment.
Your users will
appreciate the consistency
and know where to
expect each control.
So a few easy things
you can do in order
to make your app more
iPhone 10 compatible--
if you're using a
background image,
it should cover
the entire screen,
including the sensor housing
and home indicator areas.
Don't try to hide these areas
or draw any special attention
to them.
Remember that the iPhone 10
has a different aspect ratio,
and compose your images in a
way that the most important
visual information
isn't lost when
they are centered and cropped.
Since you now need to support
multiple sizes of your image
files, you can use PDF or
make sure you provide both @2x
and @3x versions for
all of your images.
More specifically, Apple's
human interface guidelines
recommend using JPEG for photos,
PNG for photo realistic app
icons, and PDF for glyphs and
other flat, vector artwork
that requires high
resolution scaling.
Similar to previous devices
with new capabilities,
make sure to only use
capabilities that are supported
on the current device.
For example, don't reference
touchID on iPhone 10
and don't reference faceID
on older unsupported devices.
When placing controls,
avoid problematic positions
such as overlapping
the home indicator
or crop by the rounded corners.
Instead, insert visual
elements to prevent
cutting and overlapping.
Note that the home indicator
will change its appearance
based on the background
it's displayed on to ensure
it's visible to the user.
A couple more things you need to
know about the home indicator--
now that the Home
button is gone,
the user swipes up from
the bottom of the screen
to get back to the home screen.
This is what the home
indicator is for.
Note that it shouldn't affect
vertical swipes or scrolling
experience since
most of these start
at the middle of the screen
and not the very bottom.
If your app encourages
users to swipe
from the very bottom of the
screen, please reconsider.
If you still decide this is the
best experience for your app,
you can use the preferredScreenE
dgesDeferringSystemGestures()
method to indicate that the
first swipe will be handled
by your app, and it will
require two such swipes in order
for the home indicator
to take over.
Note that taps in the
home indicator area
are never hijacked
by the home indicator
and will always be
handled by your app.
If your app offers the
passive fullscreen experience,
such as watching a full
screen video, for example,
you can use the
prefersHomeIndicatorAutoHidden()
method.
This will cause
the home indicator
to disappear when there
is no screen interaction.
It will reappear when the user
interacts with the screen.
Make sure to only use these
two methods when it is really
the best or only solution.
Your users are used
to certain interaction
with the home indicator
and don't want
to feel trapped in your app.
And now for the
last tip and the one
you'll probably use
most often, safe areas--
in your XIB or storyboard file,
enable Use Safe Area Layout
Guides.
It won't be automatically
enabled for older files.
This will automatically
change constraints,
that are set to the
views boundaries,
to use safe areas instead.
Safe areas represent
the parts of your view
that aren't obscured by rounded
corners, the home indicator,
or the sensor housing.
So if, for example, you have
the control with constraints
to be displayed x points
from the bottom of the view,
you'll probably
want to update it
to be x points from
the bottom safe area,
so that it won't be overlapped
by the home indicator.
A specific example
for table views,
as you can see in Apple
system apps, for example,
is the table view,
itself, goes from one end
to the screen to the other.
It's easily visible
in the headers,
while the actual
content is indented
according to the safe areas.
This is mainly
visible in landscape
since there, the
left and right insets
are significantly different
than on older devices
due to the sensor housing.
I hope you found
this useful, and will
use what you learned
here in order
to provide all of your users
on all devices the best
possible user experience
while using your app.
I can assure you,
they'll appreciate it.
Until next time, I'm
Rony Rozen for Route 85.
Thanks for watching.
[MUSIC PLAYING]